could you play devil's advocate
and
try to argue for string theory
why it is something that
deserved the effort that it got
and still couldn't like if you think of
it as a flame still should be a little
flame that keeps keeps burning well i i
think the i mean the the most positive
argument for it is is all the um
you know all sorts of new ideas about
mathematics and about parts of physics
really emerged from it so it was very a
fruitful um source of
ideas and i think you know this is
actually one argument you'll definitely
which i kind of agree with they'll hear
from from whitten and from other
strengths here i said you know this is
uh
this is just such a fruitful and
inspiring idea and it's led to so many
other different things coming out of it
that you know there must be something
right about this
and um yeah that's yeah okay that anyway
i think that that's probably the strong
the strongest thing that they that that
they've got um but you you don't think
there's
aspects to it that could be uh
neighboring to to just to a theory that
does unify everything to a theory of
everything like it could it may not be
exactly um
exactly the theory but uh sticking on it
longer might get us closer to the theory
of everything
well the problem now really is that you
really don't know what it is now you've
never nobody has ever kind of come up
with this non-perturbative
theory so there
it's become more and more
frustrating and an odd activity to try
to argue with the string theorists about
string theory because it's become
less and less well-defined what what
what it is
and it's become actually more and more
kind of a whether
you have this weird phenomenon of people
calling themselves string theorists
when they've never actually worked on
any theory were there any strings
anywhere
so what has actually happened kind of
sociologically is that
you started out with this fairly
well-defined proposal and then
i would argue because that didn't work
people and
branched out in all sorts of directions
doing all sorts of things that became
farther and farther removed from that
and for sociological reasons the ones
who kind of
started out
or now or or were trained by the people
who worked on that have now
become this string string theorists and
um
and
but but but it's become
almost more kind of a tribal denominator
than a um
i think so it's very hard to know what
you're arguing about when you're arguing
about string theory these days well to
push back on that a little bit i mean
string theory it's just a term right it
doesn't
like you could uh like this is the way
language evolves
is it could start to represent something
more than just the theory that involves
strings it could represent the uh the
effort
to unify the laws of physics right yeah
and uh at high dimensions with these
super tiny objects right or something
like that i mean we can sort of uh put
string theory aside so for example
neural networks in the space of machine
learning
there was a
time when they were extremely popular
they became much much less popular to a
point where if you mentioned you'll
notice you're getting no funding
and uh you're not going to be respected
at conferences and then once again
uh neural networks became all the all
the rage about 10 15 years ago and as it
goes up and down and a lot of people
would argue that
using terminology like machine learning
and deep learning is um
is
you know often misused over general
you know everything that works is deep
learning everything that doesn't isn't
yeah something like that you know that's
just the way uh
again we're back to sociological
things but i guess what i'm trying to
get at is if if we leave the
sociological mess aside
uh do we throw out the baby with the
bath water is there some
besides the side effects of nice ideas
from the edwins of the world
is there some core truths there
that we should stick by
in in in the full
beautiful mess of a space that we call
string theory that people call string
theory
you're right it is kind of a common
problem that you know how what your what
you call some field
changes and evolves and
interesting ways as the field changes
but
i mean
i guess
what i would argue is the you know the
initial understanding of string theory
that was quite specific we're talking
about a specific idea 10-dimensional
super strings compactified in six
dimensions
that
to my mind the
the really bad thing that's happened to
the subject is that
you it's hard to get people to admit at
least publicly that that was a failure
that this really didn't work
and so
the fact of what people do is people
stop doing that and they start doing
more interesting things but they keep
telling talking to the public about
about string theory and
referring back to that idea and using
that as kind of the starting point and
this kind of the
the place where that
the whole
where the whole tribe starts and
everything else comes from and so the
problem with this is that having as your
as your initial name and what what
everything points back to
something which
um
which really didn't work out it kind of
makes everybody makes everything you've
created this potentially very very
interesting field with interesting
things happening but
you know
people in
graduate school take courses on string
theory and everything kind of and this
is what you tell the public in which you
continually pointing back so you're
continually pointing back to this idea
which never worked out as you're
guiding
inspiration and it really kind of
deforms the whole your whole way of um
your your hopes of making progress and
that's to me i think you know the kind
of worst thing that has happened in this
field okay sure so there's a lack of
transparency and sort of authenticity
about communicating the things that
failed
uh in the past and so you don't have a
clear picture of
like firm ground that you're standing on
again those are sociological things and
yeah
i i
there's a bunch of questions i want to
ask you so one
what's your intuition about
why the original idea failed so what can
you say about
why
you're pretty sure has it has failed
you know and the initial idea was as i
tried to explain it it was quite
seductive in that that you you could see
why whitton and others got excited by it
it was um
you know it
at the time it looked like there were
only a few these possible clubby house
that would work and it looked like okay
we just have to understand this very
specific
model in these very specific six mental
spaces and we're gonna get everything
and so it was a very subjective idea but
it just
you know as people
learn worked more and more about it it
just didn't um
they just kind of realized that they're
just more and more things you can do
with these six dimensions and you can't
and this this is just not going to work
meaning like it's
i mean
what was the failure um
mode here is is you could just have an
infinite number of possibilities that
you could do so it's you can come up
with any theory you want you can fit
quantum mechanics you can
you can explain gravity you can explain
anything you want with it right is that
the basic failure mode yeah so it's a
failure mode of kind of that this idea
ended up
being kind of being essentially empty
that it it just didn't
doesn't ends up not telling you anything
because it's consistent with
just about just about anything
and so i mean there's a complex if you
try and
talk with strengtheners about this now i
mean there's a there's an argument
there's a long argument over this about
whether um
you know
oh no no maybe there still are
constraints coming coming out of this
idea or not and or maybe we live in a
multiverse and
you know every everything is true anyway
so
you can there are various ways you can
kind of
the strength here is i kind of react
react to this kind of argument that i'm
making but i try to hold on to it
you